I want to talk about one of your other
Colorado Sons for a minute Travis Hunter
um yeah I mean first off when you say
his name it's just like he's so he's him
good he's him he's him in every bit in
every aspect he is him like we have
never seen someone like Travis and you
won't Travis loves the game
loves to prepare
loves to study he's in love with the
process of it and a lot of people that
are projected the way he's projected
ain't they just want it to be that guy
and they relied on
this story
to be told in them not working towards
it Travis wanted I think at 5 30 or 6
a.m every game day morning I get a text
let's go
NC we play tonight game so last week he
was late it was like came about nine I
say you late
let's go
[Laughter]
I know he was tired I just wanted you to
sleep in yeah
I did this for you yeah
but I I love him to life yeah and he is
so complete as a player even as a person
Travis don't care about no jewelry
Travis don't care about no high priced
cars Travis want to fish want to play
video games want to spend time with his
his girlfriend
and want to be the best that he can be
that's who Travis is he's really
a he really he's like Dion really
he's like him he's really is in so many
aspects